unlike cell surface receptors which are
displayed on the cell surface the
intracellular receptors remain in the
cytoplasm
when ligand is not bound they are held
together and inhibited by the heat shock
protein 90.
upon ligand binding the heat shock
protein dissociates and frees up the
intracellular receptor it can now freely
move and translocate into the nucleus
once in the nucleus the intracellular
receptors can dimerize and bind to
specific region known as response
elements upon binding to response
element they can initiate transcription
of the target genes and thereby bringing
the cellular response of this signaling
Cascade
here are few examples of intracellular
receptors
glucocorticoid
mineralocorticoid Androgen and
progesterone receptors following this
category